in the UK and many other countries
houses are expensive very expensive
prices have been rising consistently for
many decades in England prices rose by
four thousand two hundred and fifty five
percent between 1971 and 2011 if the
price of a supermarket chicken had
inflated by the same rate it would cost
51 pounds 18 P by now around 1950 you
could get a three-bedroom house in
Northwest London on the northern line
between West Finchley and Woodside Park
for just one thousand and fifty pounds
this was two and a half times the
average wage of four hundred pounds a
year the head teacher of the local
school could very comfortably have
bought this kind of house with a total
mortgage somewhere around twice their
annual salary today a similar house in
the same area would cost close to 1
million pounds 40 times the average
income it's nearly ten times the salary
of the local head teacher house prices
in the UK haven't just increased they
have skyrocketed but why is housing so
expensive the cost of houses has very
little to do with the building materials
the value is almost all in the land on
which the house sits so why does land
cost so much well one reason is that
demand for housing keeps growing the UK
population increases by between 300 and
400 thousand people a year and also the
number of people in each household is
getting smaller more people live alone
or just as couples without children so
the demand for accommodation is growing
all the time in order to keep up with
the demand the UK would need about
240,000 new flats and houses a year it's
building less than half of this that's
not just a UK problem France is building
only 330 of the 500 thousand new homes
needed per annum major cities fare worse
London will face a shortfall of over 700
thousand homes by 2030 one in response
to the cost of housing crisis
governments have tried to intervene to
help people to buy their own home in the
u.s. there are schemes like the Federal
Home Loan Banks and the Community
Reinvestment Act in the UK there's help
to buy and there are interest-free loans
in France the underlying idea is that
people would buy houses if only they had
the money but really most governments
are just crying crocodile tears about
property prices they know that the bulk
of their voters actually like expensive
houses a lot the number of people who
want new houses at any time is very
small only 10% or so in relation to the
huge numbers who already have a home and
therefore the property owning side of
society has a vested interest in seeing
the value of homes go up creating easy
credit doesn't actually make housing
more affordable the real issue is one of
supply if you simply ease credit without
increasing supply you'll just Stoke
house inflation which is precisely
what's happened it's the same with a big
expansion of mortgage lending you may be
able to borrow more but so can other
people you're all chasing the same
limited number of homes so this just
pushes prices up and up so why is
building houses so difficult well
because there's enormous opposition to
the building of new homes and great
restrictions on the use of land there
are lots of immediate answers to do with
planning regulations and zoning but dig
deeper and what we have really are
society-wide fears of new housing for
one larger reason above all others
because almost all new housing
developments are very very ugly and no
one in their right mind wants a new
development anywhere near them most of
the large housing developments built in
the south east of england in the last 25
years share one common generally
undiscussed feature they're very ugly or
to be more precise they're far uglier
than the countryside that they've
replaced in the mid 18th century people
looked on without dismay as the hills
around the little town of Bath were
given up to a queen square the Royal
Crescent and Somerset place likewise a
little further back when the wetlands
scrubby reed beds in sandy islands at
the mouth of the river PO was sacrificed
to urban expansion few people were
likely to have raised protests given
what would come to replace them the city
of venice history shows us that people
don't object a new housing per se they
object when the houses are less
beautiful than the natural landscape
they have devoured this starts to
isolate the cause of expensive houses as
well as point the way to a solution to
the issue
it is literally ugliness
that is largely to blame for the current
social catastrophe of high house prices
what seems like negative and entrenched
NIMBYism is at heart and inarticulate
disguise but understandable plea for
grace elegance and a touch of grandeur
in architecture we love towns and cities
when they are attractive but we've no
confidence we can make today the kinds
of places we actually really like and
the reason for that has nothing to do
with prices the argument isn't that we
should build replicas of George and
crescents let alone rows of canalside
gothic palaces any more than it would be
an idea for someone who loved the
English language to begin addressing
strangers in Shakespearean dialect the
answer is to create housing developments
in the best architectural idiom of our
times places like for example the
exceptional accordion scheme in the
suburbs of Cambridge to which
unsurprisingly no one objected solving
the housing crisis requires that we get
better at grasping the nature of the
problem we're facing the issue isn't
stubborn selfishness it's a longing that
we shouldn't build unless we can build
beautifully crack that and no one will
mind a felled trees too much and
mortgages will come down too so what's
the solution it's to stop thinking that
creating credit for house purchases does
anything it just Stokes house inflation
what we should be doing is creating
not-for-profit housing corporations that
are incentivized by volumes rather than
prices reached and most importantly we
should build so beautifully that no one
Minds a patch of land near them being
developed tantalizingly all this could
be done